im änderungen dass man einfach richtiges
cabrio für die tamilen in der schweiz
sind die hindu tempel wichtige
begegnungsort für die italienischen
einwanderer waren dafür die diakonie
soziale barriere oder die missione
cattolica doch die italiener brauchen
diese begegnungsorte nicht mehr so
dringend längst haben wir sie mitsamt
ihrer italiani parteien gescheitert
doch wir sehen dass die italo fell sind
sie noch italiener oder schon schweizer
die spürbare sowohl kandidaten fand ich
schon immer als fangfrage wie man weder
beantworten kann
sein lebenslauf ist beispielhaft für
eine gekonnte aufgewachsen als sohn
italienischer einwanderer ist der halter
professor am institut für migration in
neuburg hat die mieterstruktur zünde mir
aber doch immer dann quasi dazu erfährt
oder die wir dort machte dort weiter
ausbildet und nordisch dass ich den
menschlichen situation ist unnütz
identifikation
danke
ein kürzlich erschienener fotoband ist
eine hommage an alle italienerinnen und
italiener die in der schweiz fuss
gefasst haben
bruder und hosen street gab
wie seine eltern kamen zehntausende
italiener in den fünfziger und sechziger
jahren in die schweiz
mangels arbeit in ihrer heimat voller
hoffnungen auf ein gutes wir waren sie
wohl gelegten für ihre arbeitskraft aber
lange nicht wirklich akzeptiert
untergebracht in baracken am rand der
gesellschaft geduldete gäste auf zeit
doch sie blieben und prägten nach und
nach den schweizer alpen mit ihrem
anderen liegen oft gescholten als zinke
wie es auch der liedermacher erlebte ist
diplom-betriebswirt doch ich dazu
russland gemacht ob er dadurch in ihrer
einsamkeit waren für viele die
migrantenvereine eine art zweite heimat
[Musik]
und es gibt sie noch heute wenn auch mit
geringerer bedeutung
zum beispiel die colonia libera italiana
in neuenburg gefragt sind hier etwa
tipps zum schweizer steuer oder
vorsorgesystem all jene die heute
einwandern und bio oder seltsam klingt
trotz internet und facebook noch heute
nicht durchblicken es hier läuft
francesco bruni hingegen lebt seit über
50 jahren hier mit einer schweizerin
verheiratet ist der ehemalige
industrieberater einzige in seiner
familie die er noch einen italienischen
pass ab ich will den schweizer pass
nicht hoffen ihren kilo tomaten und
radioonkologie pomodoro wenn ich ihn
verdiene geht es in ihrer medizin
übernächtigt integration ja aber nicht
um jeden preis
[Musik]
schließlich hat die talente längst ihren
festen platz im schweizer alltag
bei früh schimpfwort wartet heute stolz
betont auch dass ein zeichen fürs
angekommen sein
die italienischen gold sie im zürcher
langstrasse sind mehr als ein geheimtipp
inhaber von okada hat diese kunst auf
ist er mitgebracht
[Musik]
seine spezialität die pompöse hochzeit
tauchen schweizer ist er schon lange und
doch konnte herkunft zuallererst nicht
sagen
auch annika zion doch die lehrtochter
hat italienische ändern
wie empfindet sie in dieser frage wenn
ich bei natürlich für der bauer sein
denn wenn es arbeit
das musste ich immer der schweizer
parteien die integration der italiener
ist auch so eine erfolgsgeschichte
sie kamen auf einfache milieu haben sich
in ihrer neuen heimat nach oben
gearbeitet
früher geächtet heute geachtet
was können wir aus der geschichte der
italiener lernen für die
herausforderungen von morgen
[Musik]
kamera bereits 80 auf die möglichst
viele zuschauer wenig der geliebten
veränderung durch heben integration ist
also eine aufgabe für alle institute ab
familien sind ja sehr oft ist es wenn
sie also perfekt integriert